I've said many times I'm a big defender
of people's rights but your rights do
not include the right to trample other
people's rights or the right to force
people to believe things they don't
believe or say things they don't want to
say and so on as soon as you're trying
to do that you're the one who's out of
order because I would never try to force
I have a lot of strong beliefs in this
world right but I am not trying to force
them upon anyone I will even say so look
you are allowed to believe that you're a
man and a woman's body you're allowed to
believe you're a woman you're allowed to
believe whatever you want I do not I'm
not compelled you don't have a right to
make me validate that